this is the plot involving an iranian
dissident
and the female spy who lured him to
istanbul
the network of men who schemed to trap
him and the late night meeting where he
was kidnapped and smuggled to iran
habib who has swedish citizenship now
faces public execution
turkish investigators claimed they
uncovered an elaborate abduction plan
carried out on their soil by iranian
intelligence
the honey trap was this young woman
according to the turkish authorities
in these pictures she's seen checking in
for a flight to istanbul
in front of her and in the baseball cap
is a man accused of being part of the
same kidnapping
the couple are next spotted two hours
later in istanbul
they briefly interact turkish
investigators say the seduction and
kidnap plan
is now well underway outside the
istanbul airport security cameras again
pick up the young woman
identified as sabarin saeedy she's
accused of persuading the iranian
dissident to meet her in istanbul
for a romantic tryst she gets into a
yellow taxi
with the lovers rendezvous set for the
following day according to turkish
intelligence
her male companion is also spotted
setting off to take one of the many
buses
into the city center the following day
is set for the kidnap
hours before the victim arrives three of
the gang are seen meeting in a city
center cafe
a short time later two of the men are
seen leaving and are picked up moments
after that
seen here on the left at the
neighbouring hardware store
where they go about buying cable ties of
different sizes
turkish investigators say these will
later be used to tie habib chubs hands
and feet
just before seven security cameras pick
up their victim
at passport control in istanbul
mr chubb is spotted walking through the
airport to go to a mobile phone counter
where he appears to buy a sim card about
an hour after he's arrived in turkey
he's seen
getting into a blue taxi the journey
from the airport is about 77 kilometers
to the rendezvous point at a petrol
station in the city's west
it takes him nearly two hours before he
gets there security cameras show a white
transporter arriving
you can see it at the top of the screen
they're popular in the city amongst
private taxi drivers
turkish officials say the people inside
a dark saloon car
which drives through the petrol full
court are working in tandem
they wait in the nearby fast food lay-by
mr chubb's blue taxi
is seen sweeping into the petrol station
and after checking his female friend is
waiting
he collects his case from the boot of
the car and heads off to meet her
the petrol station which was the meeting
point looks quite different in daylight
i'm taking the same route that the
iranian dissident took that night
and round the corner is where he thought
he was going to be meeting his female
contact
aware the van was parked but once there
the turkish authorities say
he was kidnapped drugged and tied up and
within hours he would be on route to
being smuggled across the border to iran
the gang accused of the kidnap travelled
through the night according to the
turkish investigation
but their first pit stop was at a petrol
station about 80 kilometers away
security cameras show the same
transporter pulling in to fill up with
petrol
turkish officials say habib chab is
inside at this point heavily sedated and
tied down
whilst one of the gang goes into the
garage shop to buy refreshments
they continue the journey which is a
marathon 18-hour road trip across the
country about
1600 kilometers east to the town of van
not far from the iranian border
the following day by late afternoon the
transporter is seen in van center
this time with a smaller white car
accompanying it
turkish intelligence say the iranian
dissident is being taken
to a house on the town's edge the same
white car is seen leaving about an hour
later
heading in the direction of the iranian
border where the turkish authorities say
he smuggled across
two days later chubb appears on iranian
state television
in an elaborate report and where he's
pictured blindfolded he's heard
confessing to a terror attack on a
military parade
two years ago
other iranian dissidents insist that
confession was forced from him
and he's a political dissident who'd
been living in sweden for more than a
decade
his friends say he faces being executed
and want the eu to step in urgently
so they can use their diplomacy and
bring him back at least to save you know
their
their reputation save their power this
is very important for us you know
because we believe in in the european
you know
community anyway the turkish authorities
have made a string of arrests
after claims the kidnap was part of a
prisoner swap with iran
that's been vehemently denied the exact
involvement of the young woman at the
center of it all
is still shrouded in mystery whatever
the truth
turkish investigators say she was
smuggled back inside iran
leaving shocked iranian dissidents all
over europe wondering just how safe they
are
alex crawford sky news in istanbul